i'm gonna go in levels of cuteness this
one
get in there guys hello beautiful guys
guys guys guys guys i'm so sorry i
forgot your question again hello puppy
you can go to sleep and live with us in
my apartment because you're gonna be
our puppy what's up guys very exciting
day today i am back with buzzfeed and i
am gonna get to sit down with some
puppies and answer some wonderful
questions i'm sure i won't answer any of
the questions because i will be so
infatuated by these wonderful little
puppies so i'm very excited to be back
the first person to be back let's do
this please bring me puppies
[Music]
are they gonna bring them all at once oh
oh hello
hello
little puppy
oh no
it's okay
oh
oh
he smells so good hello
hello
oh hello
[Music]
it was amazing it was incredible it's a
film about exploration so it made sense
to us that we needed to be on practical
locations you know in barcelona look at
that puppy i wonder what they think is
going on this one is double cute head oh
do you want to go play go play
what was your question
my favorite stunt in the uncharted look
at these dogs
stop it guys this is beautiful this
little one you so you're like me you're
the little one hello i think this one's
my favorite no no no it's okay i'll
protect you come up here oh
[Music]
little belly scratch what was your
question again what are we talking about
favorite stunts uh there's a stunt in
the movie hello this is a big one he's
gonna be a big dog my favorite stunt to
film an uncharted
oh no
careful careful careful i like the stunt
where i fall out the back of the plane i
get hit by the car that was a lot of fun
it was very nerve-wracking my mum came
to see me that day
um and that was a lot of fun oh wow this
one is now loving my shoes these aren't
my shoes i'm borrowing them so you can
do whatever you want to them mate come
on get in there
get in there do you ever get anything
done in these interviews
[Music]
the first scene we filmed was us in the
crypt and it was very fun i was very
excited to meet him i've been a big fan
of his for a long time come here puppy
uh and we were good friends we had a
good time and you know it was one of
those things where we didn't have to
force the chemistry which was really
nice i love the fact that this dog is
chewing on these shoes louboutins
are they tasty the shoes hello beautiful
my favorite thing to shoot with sofia is
the scene where she knocks me out with
the gun because it's one of those things
where it really annoys me in films when
people play unconscious but you can see
them like
oh you can see them like catch
themselves as they hit the floor wow
these dogs are ripping these shoes man
i can't wait to send these back to
christian the booty and be like i'm so
sorry it's quite cute as well their
little teeth can't quite get into it
what would i like to see i'd like to
travel the world some more you know
obviously with this film because of
covid we weren't able to um travel
everywhere we wanted to go so it'd be
nice to make another movie and um and
just travel some more you know and get
to see the world and make a movie and
hello puppy oh hello puppy yeah that
would be fun this one just wants to go
to bed you can go to sleep and live with
us in my apartment because you're gonna
be
our puppy
[Music]
if i could do a lipstick about i would
choose
i would do a song from tiktik boom and
impersonate him
hello oh i'm gonna lie down with you
not so much a funny story but um this
dog loves my shoes not so much a funny
story but i do remember um guys guys
guys guys guys just being really felt
feeling really bad about lying to
everyone all the time because everyone
really wanted to know and i just was
constantly lying about the fact that
they weren't in the film where are you
going mate this one has stopped nimble
in my shoes and started nibbling my
ankle this is a very cute one he or she
she
i mean down he always answers when i
call him down he probably would answer
hello mate i'm gonna go in levels of
cuteness this one is pretty cute maybe
that's what we need guys is a team dog
we're about to shoot a tv show here in
new york for the next seven months and
maybe what
we need
is a team are you okay mate relax bro
no but i am about to take a puppy home
from this interview now i've taken loads
of props home i steal props all the time
with permission sometimes i love that
they had nibbling on these shoes how
much are these shoes 1800 bucks
get in there guys
my stylist lore is probably having a fit
right now
[Music]
i would be an euphoria i think i'd be a
really good maddie i'm a big euphoria
fan i love the show and i love season
two i visited a lot while they were
shooting it and i really really enjoyed
it oh he's up again i would love to
guest star we'll just be an extra in it
or maybe i am you just don't know
[Music]
careful careful your mate is trying to
sleep there i haven't actually i have a
background in tap dancing i've been tap
dancing for years so a lot of that is
going to be sort of relearning stuff i
already know but i'm very excited we're
very early stages of development so i
still haven't read a script yet but it's
very exciting but not as exciting as the
fact that this dog chose me to come home
with me
i would probably just go and walk around
town
and go and visit all the favorite spots
i used to go as a kid and enjoy which i
can't go to anymore someone made a bad
smell and it wasn't me
i can't believe how soft they are
you're a little terror you are
he's like you're all trying to sleep get
up
i think arvin russell would probably be
the trickiest one to get along with
please get in there and get comfy that
would be so cute now you're just going
to walk all over him i think nathan
drake and peter parker would really get
along they're both very adventurous they
like doing the right thing hey
oh there's a shoe there mate
[Music]
i think for me was when buzzfeed invited
me back
out out
careful was when they invited me back to
do puppies 2.0 we are not gonna be able
to give any of these clothes back there
is a hole in my trousers and these are
actually my socks
[Music]
i've got some amazing
that is so cute how is that comfortable
for him on the bottom no guys guys
i'm so sorry i'll protect you guys you
can go back to sleep i've had some
pretty cool fan art like loads of really
great fan art which has been a lot of
fun some of the fans are so talented and
they do amazing stuff and it's really
expressionistic and really different and
so i that's the stuff i really like ow
got sharp little teeth man come and join
the cuddle come and join this cuddle
any book i probably have to say the
harry potter books like to go back and
read those again was pretty magical i'd
love to go and re-watch or relive the
time i saw spider-man 1 for the first
time i was very excited obviously it was
a big thing for me to be in that movie
and it was life-changing so the day that
i got to go and see that was incredibly
exciting hello hello what's what are you
going through
what are you going through
what's happening here mate this is the
one for me
and that is definitely look at this guy
yeah get it get it get it
oh
i know we're gonna put you up here so
you're out of the way there we go look
they've all left and there's one final
candidate he likes the taste of my
makeup
oh i know hey guys i charted this out
guys i'm trying to record my lines i
charted this out please go to the cinema
and enjoy it i hope you have a wonderful
ride and enjoy the escapism so chris
evans he hasn't got to do it once evans
i don't even think you need to promote
anything i think you could just come
here and do this he has a beautiful dog
as well should bring your dog and then
you can have another little dog all of
these beautiful puppies that you've seen
here are adoptable they are from the
north shore animal league america so
please find these little guys a
wonderful home they all deserve it
they're all very cute and this one's my
favorite and i'd like to apologize to
christian labusine because i will not be
paying for these shoes
you